okay here we go second video in English
this time it gets a little bit more even
I guess was just an I am and not my
camera end okay I get some ratty
position and like surrenders his light
square bishop rather voluntarily nothing
before might be a good idea here to
quickly get in b5 he gave me this some
strong bishop on three and I think it's
a good idea to make immediate use of it
if for might be a problem though so I
get out of the diagonal yeah
let's to play forward this also could be
weakness at some point but I think it's
no problem to play d3 here it's not that
I'm in a huge rush I guess I'll 95 okay
interesting idea I play Bishop d2 in my
takeoff history and play e4 Bishop g7
year three and then it's got a fork
working on earth - so maybe it's the
easiest to just take it and then play on
Queen b3 yeah it was clear that you
young would play that but I'm not sure
if this was really a great idea
and so the Pony Youth Forum also could
could be weak at some point
yeah 94 is good okay I guess well this
should this should be two maybe this may
be better to exchange the bishop hmm not
sure a paper should be three
you know yeah this looks looks okay for
black again maybe I needed to do
something else instead of Bishop and she
had set up night xt5 it really helped
like to to free its position a bit well
I still like my position it's it's it's
not a not a big problem or something but
I should have really gotten some
advantage out of the a little bit
strange
strangely played opening yeah my idea
was to to get the bishop here too and to
provoke some some weaknesses not sure if
it will lead to anything but
check it still looks child equal but I
might I might have a tiny advantage
because of the king position which still
looks a bit vulnerable one idea for
instance could be to somehow switch the
position here of the Queen and Bishop
two to get some some battery going but
it's certainly not easy I try to make
some progress on the Queen side as well
hmm
this really looks like um is intending
to pay to play g5 here
hmm
so out of a very dry position we
actually got some interesting things
going Queen g8 for instance could be an
idea from me also b7 is hanging but no
idea how important that is
hmmm no idea what is playing now Quincy
seven-hour lantern g8 which is at least
I'm comfortable no idea if this is
something serious but I wouldn't like it
if I were black yeah you know we'll take
our queen g8 no idea but Ally I really
like to to go into there to the position
here
I'm not sure if I actually threatened
anything but it's it's looking dangerous
yeah but if I take now time morning I
would some might have aged five at some
point I'm gonna queen g6 for instance
I'm did so it's not obvious how he could
could get any counter play Queen g7 yeah
he likes to exchange it this is
understandable do I have something to
prevent that well not really but I could
I could maybe play play b5 here Queen g7
at least then shouldn't work because of
the exchange it takes on b7 I think that
I got some breakthrough ideas and and
also all this this point is hanging as
well of course 3 g7 is not possible at
all yeah take you to get in some quick
moves
check-check
check
check-check
I'd like to avoid the perpetual but I
don't I don't really see how check game
draw yes so the suspect us is so somehow
good for me but I don't see how too hard
to avoid it
Bishop d7 the computer wants to play and
then it it gives King FA not King d8 why
not King d8 and maybe Queen a seven or
something
mm-hmm yeah my from practical point of
view was the 17 seconds against 24 I got
to take the perpetual everything at some
point this should have been good for me
here but it's of course difficult to
play any exact moves of this this time
of this time left of 30 seconds what
interesting game would really look very
very boring but I really got a little
bit of play here